Let's consider the
motion of an object that
is under the action of a force.
So we have some force that's
acting on this object.
And we have a little
displacement ds.
So this is a small
displacement of the object.
Then we know that
the small amount
of work done by the action
of this force is F.ds.
And the rate of doing work,
so let's now introduce
the concept of power, which
is the rate of doing work.
That is, F.ds over dt.
And ds dt is just the
velocity of the object.
So we see very
simply that when we
talk about power, and sometimes
people use the symbol p,
although we can also talk
about pressure and momentum,
so it's a little bit tricky.
But here, the power
is F.v. And power
is a concept that will appear
in many different settings.